welcome back to the Jenna Dewan podcast
this episode of the gingerly podcast is
brought to you by five star guys
back-to-school is gonna come and you're
gonna need some school supplies go five
star to get your school supply needs
they have awesome backpacks build
quality built to last you can enter the
sweepstakes today at need MEA d5 spelled
out FIV G Starcom slash sweeps there's
an awesome sweepstakes going on what can
you win well funny you asked because you
can win things like this if you guys
follow the vlogs you know that came to
the house and I didn't know that we had
five stars the sponsor yeah it's officer
who sent me a brand-new backpack five
star did so guys go check it out Mead
five star cops are sweepstakes more on
that later on not a student I just want
some supply needs a bad life everyone
needs something yeah that's a life do
you live it's also brought to you by
tracker tracker makes losing things a
thing of the past to basically a coin
size device that you can track misplace
keys wallets bags computers things like
that super super helpful super practical
pretty incredible you can go right now
to the tracker comm that's th e tracker
calm and enter promo code Jenna Julian
for 30% off your entire order with track
incredibly helpful and thank you to were
supposed to only get one of those to my
mom one time I found her keys in the
piano yeah my mom my mom loses
everything she was their keys her felt
like she goes through like three phones
here well don't you ask again well it's
Sunday
we normally record Thursday to Saturday
sometime in that span of days we
recording on a Sunday today because we
wanted to post UFC to
Podcast yes we watched it last night
I have stupid people do you know what
the figures were for I looked it up the
pay-per-view buys are not available yet
mmm and even when they do come out a lot
of them are kind of weird figures
because people are reporting facts there
are facts and I do have some information
up so I thought we would oh by the way
guys my hair is not blonde the green
screen has to key out my groups my
yellow hair for it to be that like a
peer and this in the shot so I saw
yellow but I am going the dark panel
person you cute pill I'll see it cuz
you're pale alright so I came up with a
game well first I want to just have us
react we I think we should just kind of
have a like a debrief if you will of
like our thoughts on the on the fight
with all that crazy hype leading up to
it what we think our reactions and then
we'll go into the game that I developed
ok why don't you why don't you start
I'll start with the first two nights of
UFC 200 were far superior to the main
night of UFC 200 yeah so if you guys
aren't familiar Thursday night and
Friday night there were separate fights
as like a giant fight week spectacular
they had three fights including
Saturday's right yeah like the Johanna
Claudia fight was incredible and that
was the night before that was Friday
night that was the headlining fight
instead of Misha and I would have been
ok with it and Eddie Alvarez he thought
Thursday night that was an amazing fight
it was it was weird the whole thing was
weird from start to finish it was weird
I for one am in the school of thought
that Anderson Silva taking that fight on
48 hours wasn't really in there to beat
DC he wasn't he was just there to get
paid and not hurt get hurt I I don't
think he was trying to fight period
riddle me if I'm a conspiracy theorist
that's my conspiracy wasn't gonna go in
there and beat up DC I don't think it's
as much of a
conspiracy as it is just plain facts he
literally said after the fight which
we'll all of us like predicted he hadn't
trained one hour for this fight like Yin
trained at all he was on the couch and
he flew to Vegas to fight like you can
only fight so well you can only be such
a good Anderson no is he gonna go in
there and [ __ ] beat his ass a [ __ ]
in shape like motivated Anderson could
possibly do that yes but you saw he had
a couple nice nice you know combos and
then other than that he was just like
helpless on the ground oh yeah yeah I
feel like it was just like he took the
fight and was just gonna go in there and
get paid and and let he see what it felt
like
yeah that's what folks so that was weird
those words and then what else was weird
Frankie Edgar losing was upsetting it
wasn't weird at least I was a fight but
frustrating for Frankie's couldn't touch
although but um it was weird it was just
weird every single fight was weird the
Brock Lesnar fight was weird
it was weird I feel weird I don't know I
think weird is the best is the best
description of the entire fight started
and it got weird and then the weird
ended and then another weird fight
started yeah you know honestly I think
that the last normal fight that we saw
was Kane versus Brown yeah wheel kicks
came through a [ __ ] wheel - he landed
one we'll get to that later
they looked perfect I mean we saw a
[ __ ] vintage Cain Velasquez which I
was so excited about because after you
have so many injuries and you [ __ ]
sit on the [ __ ] bench for so long you
come back and you so many times he sucks
you know every guy who goes through that
every guy or girl goes to that nine and
ten times comes back a completely
different fighter for the worst and came
to none he came back full fledged came
to us because it was awesome he's one of
the most exciting fighters to watch hmm
but no I agree I mean angry what are
your thoughts
okay so Julian said I was sad Wednesday
night
because when John Jones dropped out of
this fight I felt like the
full potential of this card was a thing
of the past there was no way this fight
was what this whole entire night was
going to be what we thought or what we
even like would have settled for it was
going to be kind of crappy and it was
and I think a lot of people like there's
you know there's that you know the the
curse is like the curse is like in
everything like basically like I go on
the mmm a subreddit put a lot of you
know anyone you talk to you'll talk
about in MMA how when you have a great
card coming up the MMA gods will
sacrifice one of those fights to make
the card happen because it's too good to
happen all you know and so UFC 200
initially was McGregor vs. right it was
um who's who else [ __ ] I'm blanking
right now there was McGregor Diaz and oh
yeah no Jones DC and then Brock Lesnar
against Mark Hunt and two of those
fights didn't happen and this week I'm
Monday or something someone posted on
the subreddit was like that's can you
believe it this is actually happening
and everyone that comes was like [ __ ]
you dude what the hell like how dare you
and of course it you know Jon Jones
crapped out but I like back back to what
I'm saying is like John Jones dropping
out of this fight in the fashion that he
dropped out was just such a like a kick
to the gut that nobody could really get
that excited for the fight anymore
you heard it if you're watching there
was no energy in that arena people were
not because it was weird
there was weird everything was weird it
could have been epic but instead of epic
it was like the how these tweaks that
were meant to make it epic like the gold
octagon and the and the weird screen but
that all turned weird because that's the
telling me that screen looked like not a
single person in there could actually
see what was being on that screen and
then they were televising it to us and
we couldn't really see hocus on that
screen like that screen benefited no one
nobody popped out of it when they could
like brought it up yeah oh my gosh okay
I want to give just a couple more um a
lot like I feel bad for DC once again
because I feel like I'm always feeling
bad for DC because what is he gonna do
say no and not find Anderson or no he
[ __ ] he fought Anderson which a lot of
people wouldn't have done
he played it safe because you can't lose
that fight if you're him
you just cannot so he fought his fight
and yeah it wasn't exciting it wasn't
the fight people wanted to see or paid
to see or you know flew to Vegas to see
or whatever but it wasn't always and
then the whole Brock thing for some
reason that drew booze like Brock was on
the shelf for five years and he comes
back and he dominates a top five
opponent that's [ __ ] impressive it's
impressive and he almost finished him -
like he didn't completely you know just
smother him on the ground and just not
do anything he was aggressive he landed
punches he like really hurt him you know
for a second I'm still hoping for a mark
on top of the head grazing tono just
magically not like that's not that's
what makes this win for Brock all the
more impressive you know okay Brock you
know Mark Hunt is terrifying
it's very impressive but and then to
make sure not showing up everything was
weird it's nothing when I thought I was
gonna go over once me she had made it
out of that first round she would've
been fine all you have to do is make it
out of that first round against Amanda
Nunez and she's done yeah but there's
one woman on the planet who was built to
do that and his Miesha Tate she is the
only fighter who is good at weathering
storms and coming back like I don't know
what happened she just had a weird night
huh yeah if you want I want no no I'm
sorry what were you gonna say glad I
just like the John Jones thing the
pulling out the watching the video with
Dana breaking the news so DC was
absolutely heartbreaking it was so sad
to watch and hard to watch because all
he wants to do is fight and we've talked
about this with DC that your career is
in someone else's hands right now not
like all of it but a lot of it right now
more than it should be and John Jones
keeps [ __ ] up do you think in the
court of public opinion is this like
that like I know we've all been saying
it for a long time like I'm sick of him
he's [ __ ] like squandering his
opportunities you know not acting like a
professional [ __ ] up and just not
taking it seriously and that he treats
everything like he's better than it like
he can just come back and and people
love it is this is this his last chance
it's a loaded question I think that
there were people were talking about the
fact that he potentially could be
suspended
for two years I think if that suspension
happens it could be the end of John
Jones in the UFC
very well I think the UFC like Mark was
saying the UFC should make a statement
and cut them and they should say we
don't want your [ __ ] anymore goodbye to
break record sales you were not bigger
than the company yeah sorry you you had
a chance to be greatness and you do you
blew it so you know I think if that
suspension from you sada the drug agency
anti-doping agency happens they will you
know they will cut him or even if they
don't cut him even if the UFC's like
yeah we'll see in two years two [ __ ]
years off a fighter's life I'm sorry
that's a career changer like whatever
greatness he could have ever become is
no longer a possibility it's just not
what about somebody like Nate Diaz
though didn't he get suspended
me and Nick have been suspended for
smoking weed but that's not necessarily
a career ender if you get suspended I
disagree only because it's John Jones
and you know [ __ ] top emiliano it's not
even that I just disagree because you
look at Nick Diaz and their fighting
style is so longevity based you can
fight like them way into your 30s and
40s with John Jones he's a freak [ __ ]
athlete he's someone you want to watch
fight because he's incredibly naturally
gifted he's skilled he's explosive he's
powerful he's strong that that two years
off of that style is more detrimental
the two years off of the slow and the
steady boxing that the Diaz is way in
the ground I'm just saying as a viewer
as a fan
well yeah I find it totally forgivable
if somebody gets caught smoking weed and
gets suspended rather than like going
out [ __ ] drag racing and doing the
[ __ ] cocaine and breaking a pregnant
woman's arm exactly and then and then
coming back and then failing a drug test
and all of a sudden it's like I'm just
saying it is possible for someone to get
suspended for doing stuff and come back
but this was John Jones chance which he
now again squandered and on squandered
his second or third depending on how you
look at it because I think if you know
Nate Diaz or someone that's gotten
suspended
for drugs or some [ __ ] if they get their
chance and they [ __ ] it up again you
know maybe you'd feel the same way about
them I find it hard to like anyone that
ruins second chances yeah especially in
the manner he's going to like well
especially when you're a professional
athlete like what are you here to do
well he has an active professional at
all I think you can't do your job for
years what do you do yeah but what you
were talking about how like TC his
career is kind of at the mercy of what
John Jones just decides to do it just
sucks because DC is a hard worker and
he's had an incredibly resilient life
and it's just the like you look at him
and you're like I don't I don't know
what to do but feel bad for you yeah
like you just want to you want to
achieve such greatness and you cannot
because this guy is like throwing you
under the bus at every stop yeah like
this you know what sucks is like DC
somehow lost fans on Saturday night
because of how he thought people were
pissed I mean you know one of the most
depressing things below castings are out
of his control
yeah can really control what you have
control over all of those aren't as much
as much as you like TC think about this
one of the most depressing things to
ever see is his Instagram comments
people are so mean to him man yeah I
like your a paper champ you're you're a
fake you didn't be Jones like [ __ ] off
kid I like what can he do he lost the
fight against Jones big [ __ ] he's
gonna fight him he at least would have
had a chance to show people that he was
gonna fight him this out he couldn't you
know it's a he's just the real victim
and I understand a little mix I wasn't
always a DC fan until I like wikipedia'd
him and was like wait a second like took
Italy gave him a chance a little bit and
I get it now I am a fan of his yeah and
even if he lost against John Jones I'm a
fan of it I just respect him
yeah you can't help I respect him I wish
people would show him a little more
respect me no [ __ ] but okay I also want
to talk about the fact that you had a
theory that you thought the Ronda Rousey
was gonna pop out there again do you
think that if Miesha Tate 1we Ronda
Rousey was gonna pop out and [ __ ]
challenger possibly wanted her to be
under that shimmer in so bad so
here's my thing on that pop-up hey guys
there's like a metro commercial where
she's like walking so many shoulders hey
guys that's Mike that's knockout
Ronda Conan um one of my things about
that is like I told you I was like if
Misha wins round is gonna come into the
cage after the fight and it's gonna be a
whole thing that was my that was my
logic on why they moved here two hundred
spectacular here yeah that was my that
was my logic on why that you [ __ ]
eight new news fight was moved to the
main event
instead of like saying Cormier I mean
it's not about theories I think it's a
good theory I think in theory it was a
good theory but then you see Lesnar vs.
haunt and deceive ourselves and you're
like now I get why these couldn't be the
main events these are circuses
yeah like nothing about this represents
high level mixed martial arts it just
doesn't I'm sorry
like Lesnar's amazing he's a freak
athlete and DC is awesome but Silva came
in like a dad and he had no training it
was borderline exhibition almost there
cross promoting the WWE nine stock
really weird when he's coming back after
what five [ __ ] years nobody knows
what to expect you no one's expecting it
to be like a mind-blowing fight we're
just excited to see Brock Lesnar fight
it's almost exhibition and he's got a
giant WWE whatever the [ __ ] in August
like it's not like he's going in there
to you know break somebody's [ __ ] leg
or whatever he's just in there to be its
exhibition almost not can be the main
event it was it was a freak show almost
he's got millions and millions of
dollars to make in August his career is
laughing everybody else's career he's
gonna burn that [ __ ] video game he
sits back in his corner after one round
you see him [ __ ] like laughing I
won't but he's like smiling and I was
sitting in his corner laughing his
career is laughing at everybody he's
winning yeah
he was [ __ ] winning so no matter what
he does he's winning yeah he's getting
double [ __ ] paychecks oh man double
all over the he supposedly made two
point five mil on Saturday night yeah
not to
genomic xx he's gonna make an August
when he does whatever [ __ ] WWE fight
not to mention the fights he'll make in
the future that he just set up in the US
soon by winning that fight I mean
everybody's happy for Brock
I feel no problem being your problem
take my mind exactly and like you know
that's Brock that's why it's so exciting
that he's back in the UFC cuz you're
like holy [ __ ] the one and only Brock
Lesnar but that to be like the most
incredible fight no not so they moved me
shot Nunez the headline fight and you
thought that Ronda Rousey was going to
come out yeah but now and she no she'll
show up but nothing but now that I look
now that I watched all three of those
fights I'm like you couldn't have had
anything but me some units as the main
event that was the only legitimate MMA
fight but as soon as that happened you
and I just looked at each other and
we're like this whole division is a mess
masses and women's bed way it makes no
sense it's a mess it's just there's no
logic Holly can beat Ronda Mischa can
beat Holly Ronda can beat Mischa Radha
can be Tanisha did Rhonda be the Amanda
Nunez I don't think she fought her I
don't think she thought or either
because Amanda Nunez is still her career
yeah just started Lina yeah and Nunez
can beat Mischa but Holly could beat
Nunez right did they fight [ __ ] I should
look at it's like a big yeah but that's
it's not the worst it's like a be a
giant game of rock paper since it's cool
exactly exactly it's cool though because
it's a good mess though because if you
look if you compare that to say light
heavyweight hmm light heavyweight
[ __ ] sucks
yeah okay after the Saturday night
they're talking about matching DC up
with the winner of Anthony Johnson
versus Glover Teixeira who are both just
so tired and are not talented enough to
be top 5 fighters they're just not like
light every weight is so sparse with
talent right now it's the most
frustrating thing so when you look at
Bantam weight when Championships are
getting handed over it's right you're
like holy [ __ ] is exciting it is very
you know it's same with light weight
right now tonight also it's it's so much
more satisfying to watch even though
it's a [ __ ] and a roller coaster
than to watch someone have the belt and
then not be able to fight for a while or
like dip out for a hot second like it's
annoying when that happens yes a hundred
percent I agree I like watching people
just take it
are you sittin and take it although I
adore Misha and she's been working like
a [ __ ] bulldog very entire life and
it was nice to watch her win sad to
watch her lose but like it is exciting
yeah because it's anybody's [ __ ] belt
yeah at any given time I mean isn't that
the goal
I mean Dana might argue that the goal is
to have won cash he was trying well he
was trying to make Connor that cash I
was trying to make Paige that cash got
Rhonda that cash go and every one of
them has kind of let him down because
they've lost and it's just and Jones now
it's like kind of [ __ ] himself in the
UFC it's like well Jones can't make
anybody money right now he can't even
make himself money right now hmm damn I
really wanted to see that fight I wait
when do we find out what happens to John
Jones probably in the coming week
probably this week sometime yeah I would
think they're gonna announce something
at least you sada will make a statement
on his suspension that's it or the trial
of his about whatever that some you know
come out this week they're gonna tell us
what exactly he tested positive for will
you tell us what Mark said yeah well he
basically has a I don't know the name of
a supplement company sponsor yeah
basically like pre-workout protein gain
or stuff like that
someone's bothering him no before this
fight [ __ ] that you get in the top like
bodybuilders and power lifters news
because he was training at a parenting
gym so it's natural and you got I should
use the word natural it's it's
understandable so apparently in one of
those supplements he didn't care to read
the ingredients and one of the
ingredients was a banned substance I
don't think it was I don't think it was
like blatant like [ __ ] he was juicing
but I think it was a banned substance I
think it has DHEA in it which you're not
supposed to take and I think it had a
disclaimer obviously the FDA you make
when you create a supplement you have to
put a disclaimer like if warning if you
were being tested this will not be okay
or whatever and that's there was an a
sample and a B sample a sample tested
positive he got ejected from the fight
then the B sample was still out there
everyone was like well what does B
sample than a test
that could prove I'm innocent if it's
test negative tested positive so both
samples were positive and Mele bad look
for him sounds careless sounds careless
that's what it is and and the amount of
times he apologized when he's crying at
the press conference he's like I'm sorry
sorry to UFC I'm sorry Dana I'm sorry
for me that behavior leads me to believe
that he knew he was cheating I'm sorry
because if if he didn't say he's sorry
he's acting like [ __ ] why is this
happening to me then it's like okay
maybe he might have forgotten right if
his knee jerk reaction was like super
[ __ ] angry oh my god I can't [ __ ]
believe this yeah no tears just
frustration and well because that's
that's an easier emotion to process when
something like that happens to you like
I'm so [ __ ] mad like I've done
everything that I could for you to just
sit there and cry it's sort of like yeah
maybe you did [ __ ] help and he got
caught outraged
he's upset for himself yeah he's not
sorry - Dana Marc what you were saying
I'm Marc I was he texted me like
Thursday right after the Jones news
Brooke you said what the [ __ ] happened
of John Jones and I said he apparently
didn't know there was this ingredient in
a supplement that had a band stops
substance and he said was the ingredient
a needle with a testosterone symbol on
it did he accidentally sit on it oh my
god Micah Micah was calling the mark
hunt Brock Lesnar fight a little game of
punchy face that's what Mark Hunt says
punch face yeah so anytime Mark Hunt was
asked a question about Lesnar who's like
oh I just want to play punch face punch
face nice that's funny yeah punch face
is pretty cool mm-hmm man weird night
weird [ __ ] night man yeah I mean but
for those athletes out there who do take
supplements and they aren't on the
banned substance list and you won't get
tested positive for him you're just
taking good supplements to be an awesome
athlete put them in your backpack
because 5 star has the best
awesome backpacks extra-large batch
check out this backpack okay so that you
see how this comes from the front all
the way to the back so why don't you
just like look inside there's some stuff
in there too for you why don't you wear
my supplies it what what do you fight so
this is the expandable backpack all
right it's designed with students in
mind okay it's an extra large backpack
expands to an additional 7 inches for
added storage straps distribute weight
comfortably see how the straps come from
the back to the front it distributes so
this is the expandable storage right
here see that it's like a it's like a
suitcase separate padded compartment
secures and protects laptop so there's a
laptop compartment for you guys who need
to bring your laptop to school there's a
quick and easy
expanding Oh use very easy access with
the zipper on the side which allows
lucky to hang it in your locker so if
you hang in your locker there's a quick
zipper on top that you have to hang it
to get stuff out in there we got the
five star flex hybrid note binder which
acts like a notebook works like a binder
tech dude I wish we had this kind of
school technology I was like Lisa Frank
and it just like broke all the time
because I loved it speaking of which
well this is cool your mom wanted me to
talk to you and ask you about your
Trapper Keeper trapper trapper keeper
wasn't as does this stuff though know it
like all of this stuff is just like not
what we had at all we just had paper
folders and like a trapper keeper and
that was it yeah it's pretty sweet
pieces of paper and that's why half my
[ __ ] would just get destroyed like in
this yeah I know this shit's like look
at this it's like look at this material
like nothing's getting in here what even
are you even guys show off your sweet
selfie skills and enter the express your
selfie sweepstakes create your
one-of-a-kind selfie with cool
characters fun props and more for your
chance to win one of 55
awesome prizes including the hottest
tech devices gift cards and more go to
need five-star dot-com slash sweeps to
enter the sweepstakes
alright I took a trip inside the
backpack it was good yeah yeah well
that's good
choose five-star products for all your
back to school in these guys five stars
and our other sponsor this week is
really cool it's called tracker it's
about tra CK are like track are um it's
this tiny coin sized device alright and
you can locate misplaced keys wallets
phones stuff like that just pair your
tracker to your smartphone attach it to
anything and find its precise location
with the tap of a button so say it lasts
for a year the battery lasts for a year
and then you I think switch recharge the
battery but the app will give you a
notification when when that battery is
dying so you will know to switch it out
if you lose your phone just press the
button on the tracker and your phone
rings holy connects to your phone via
the app so it can work like vice versa
you can find things with the tracker
attached or you can find your phone with
your tracker really cool can you put the
phone you Sam it you can put you can put
on your sandwich but only items listen
it you guys if you want to get 30% of
your entire order with tracker go to the
th e TR a cker the tracker you spell out
full tracker comm promo code Jenna
joining it 30% of your entire order
really cool stuff and really helpful
because everyone I know loses everything
important if you have a [ __ ] vlogging
camera you have a phone if you have a
wallet just use it or somebody tries to
steal your [ __ ] it's not boob a thank
you or a sponsor
thank you sponsor to new sponsors this
week that's exciting Wow Wow we want
alright so I got a game okay the game is
excited I'm excited can we blame Jones
so basically I compiled something tells
me that you harboring a little bit of
you know maybe a little bit I compiled
over 20 facts that happened at UFC 200
things that are factual they are not up
for debate
they literally happen and it is up to us
to figure out if we can blame John Jones
for that happening and we can debate
about it we can get crafty with it
because I feel like in a sense you can
kind of blame everything like thank
Jones Bhama oh my god all right you
wanna start yes all right so Juliana
paying you one and asked for a title
shot can we blame Jones oh I'm still
just like getting over that Juliana Pina
one yes yes we can
okay why because we can okay my excuse
to blame Jones is because if John Jones
was on the card cats and Ghana would
have been more excited to be chewing on
opinion there we go remember Juliana
Pena would have been too excited and
lost focus yes
yeah she's gonna be too excited get
Southie with John Jones up in style all
right number 2 DC somehow loses more
fans once again for doing nothing wrong
that's 100% Jones's fault oh hi Jonesy
were all number three Anderson lost his
first light heavyweight fight 100%
chances he's so goofy the goofball he is
such a good father did you see the video
Dana posted on his Instagram when Tom
Anderson stepped up why
Dana's hanging with Anderson and he
looks at the cameras like he's back and
he's like a he's self-aware he's this
self-aware Mimi yes very funny um all
right ready yeah number four the Octagon
being painted a dehydrated pea colored
gold yeah what was that has that Jones's
fault
yes it's John's fault it's all his fun
honestly think he probably sent do you
have seen email and said I'm so excited
for this big card can you please make
the to go on the color of my pee and
then he sent him a picture of his pee it
was
they could have made a gold though they
could have made it shiny and gold it was
weird that color is not gold that color
is yellow do that we're still four four
four four four four
Jones's fault it's all his fault right
number five thing we got to come up with
the reason number five Dana White's
blood pressure raising so high that it
melted his razor when he tried to shave
and shave for the face abdomen sadena
did not shave because he hadn't slept
two days because his blood pressure was
so high of John Jones his blood pressure
was so high because Dana so deeply his
fault his doctors already so mad at him
look at his face you did this Yeah right
like John Jones Dana White's doctor so
much money you're killing like three
doctors visits a week because the John
Doe number six Mike Goldberg having an
exceptionally zonked out night of
commentator oh my god like was he weird
like especially weird
so we it was commentating partners it
was really bizarre it was a couple of
times Joe just straight-up interrupted
him and was like because he was going on
about some random [ __ ] fighting styles
they really they make a foot eight okay
so he's going yes they're always going
for the arm like shut up Mike that
fighting style
he's doing his arm right now they they
showed that um the you know the pictures
of whatever fighters and what what
that's what started us like being like
is he alright cuz he was like this is
this is looking to be a great match it
was a weird pause that you were like is
he okay
what was that pause Mike Goldberg number
seven so that's obviously Jones's fault
all his fault yeah right because Mike is
like he doesn't even know he's doing
anymore he's like I was expecting John
John so now I think I'm in my I feel
like Mike was prepared for John Jones
fight everything adrenaline dump and
just did forgot how to do his job I
think the fans had an adrenaline
see bless you Mouse yeah
Matthew man all right number seven
Connor having one moment of camera time
that lasted long enough for us not to
see him until the UFC - OH - mm-hmm do
you remember that shot but he's just
like it was way too long they had no Jon
Jones backstage warming up killing some
[ __ ] paths to look at although I will
say there was really one really cool pal
show you there's one really cool picture
that someone snapped of Connor looking
at the Edgar Aldo fight look at this
picture look at Lucca Connor in this
picture it's pretty sick yeah the inside
the controller smoking out all right
both those things are Jones's fault all
right number a charge on scrying is that
John's over this fault always four words
bad stuff you think just John Jones have
to cry about right is it his own fault
don't you dare play the victim you have
any chanted life sir don't you cry boy
boy everyone else gets a cry no tears
your fault
number 9 DC crying 100% Joneses follow
my god you made DC cry why alright
number 10 Anderson eating a piece of
pizza before way and if you think I'm
lying that actually happened
eat that pizza Anderson in the UFC
embedded vlog series he's hangin out
Dana and he's eating a piece of pizza
like there's pizza in Anderson's mouth
while Dana goes up to him and says hey
you know you're undefeated at light
heavyweight right and he's like yeah
he's like why you eating pizza you gotta
you gotta fight to beautify he's like
yeah I'm underway I normally fight at
middleweight
just full-blown dadbod alright number
eleven Travis Browne finally being
beaten out how he should have been
beaten many fights ago because just
going to fall it's John John it's his
fault Travis Browne is a guy who thinks
he's just God's gift and so when he was
fighting on John Jones's card he was in
full form
like oh I'm gonna go be king because
Jones is fighting but then Jones dropped
out and Travis is like I feel weird now
but you do Travis sucks dude I'm so
happy he lost
thank you for beating him yeah but
that's you're saying it's Sean Jones's
look that's a good thing like John Jones
did it's a favor oh [ __ ] all right so
it's John Jones is fault that Travis
Browne ever won at all that's that's how
it's Ronda not entering the Octagon
event pull up that curtain and it's just
Ronda [ __ ] what's happening in Rajas
living room right now she's beating
herself up yeah all right that's fair
right John John John's fault too all
John Jones is [ __ ] number 13
during both the fights and the
commentary in between the fights the
screen graphics being so loud that you
can't hear anything
do you guys notice that like during the
fight then what you will try to heal
John he was right here Joe Rogan being
like he's pulling guard and then this
graphic appears he's looking at the
levels weren't mixed the mics did you
know some mics were [ __ ] all night
camera what the [ __ ] was a frame rate
was Arlene Everett
that's what I said before can the flick
am that was on the floor of the canvas
so just joking like basically it written
on the you know on the ground with the
fighters it was a different it was 24
frames a second the other cameras I
think were 30 or 60 that was 24 it looks
so [ __ ] weird it's very distracting
all right that strengthens all his fault
yeah clearly they built a t-mobile Arena
they built an entire [ __ ] marina in
Las Vegas for that fight not for that
fight but they used a brand new arena
and everything else sucked in it the
gray
I fix the audio everything was [ __ ] they
had a whole new arena and you can't even
get your AV together I didn't realize
that they built that arena for that no
they didn't build it for UFC 200 but it
is a new combat sports arena that was
just done all right that whole building
is his Hall yeah John Jones you did this
sit with the guilt number 14 sage
Northcutt being cut in his fight from an
elbow and bleeding in the shape of a
Reebok logo when you said that it was
cried bad thing yeah I came up with
something that was good Jeff sage
Northcutt got it in his eyes that's John
this fall number 15 the fans really had
just like no energy all night everyone
was just tired and over it was weird
they had about enough energy it's all
John Jones's love okay I have one what
Tom Brady and Justin Timberlake's
sitting next to each other
wearing matching the Skelly caps or
whatever all they probably got dressed
at each others house and went to the
fight together holding hands
John Jones's fall both of those hats
being created John Jones went to Italy
watch those hats kept those he lived in
Boston for like 60 years started the
trend gave them their hats did it went
forward in time became John Jones this
is all his fault
hundred percent fair enough number 16
the Reebok fight kits still sucking yeah
they don't look right Andrew said that
Tom Jones designed the fight kill you
said that in highlight reels out of
people's like passwords for they've been
blurring out old sponsors thanks Reebok
thanks John
number 17 Brock [ __ ] Lesnar somehow
at one point being booed do you remember
that he took Mark Hunt down and was
grinding pounding any [ __ ] got booed
because people don't like watching that
don't because they retired after DC or
taking Anderson down they were like oh
no more takedowns we're gonna yeah
because the buzzer they paid for your
circus they wanted a circus come out on
an elephant or go home John John
cause that this is your consent a text
message personally to every single
person in the audience saying boo right
now number 18 you said am a stud the
fact that the UFC decided to start cross
promoting with the WWE like a lot and
chocolate L just suddenly [ __ ] we
trust that you chuck we trusted you
comes out of nowhere to sell WWE video
you can't smile Oh John this is Jeff all
horrible look what you've done look what
you did miss nice number nineteen
Anderson getting on his knees and bowing
to his security guard after this fire
just like he was secure we were saying
that after that he was just gonna go
individually at about every six hours
they're trying to clear out the arena
and he's so bowing yeah number twenty
Cain Velasquez throwing not one but two
spinning wheel pancakes and landing it
that's John Jones
yeah because John Jones created an
alternate universe yeah that's exactly
what his throws wheel kick John Jones
treating an alternate universe by
everything that made this whole journey
new universe was never supposed to exist
but it was so weird no one had ever put
any time into it it was like gonna be
weird no one no one's gonna see it but
then John Jones [ __ ] switched
universes and was like now you have to
have the weird universe we are
ultimately in the end dimension because
of John Jones number 21 the fact that
Amanda Nunez who is it was now a
champion wearing a gold UFC belt made
125th of what Brock Lesnar made yeah I
mean I will appreciate supposedly this
is a game this is a champion and that's
all
that's awesome
so this is the figure I read which you
know taken with a grain of salt because
a lot of these figures that come out the
next day or are wrong sometimes are off
she supposedly made 100k oh and leather
made 2.5 million so that's 125th I
believe that's not fair the end so bad
apparently DC made half as much as he
was supposed to make an image cuz they
either pay Anderson ah god I I mean I
don't know why you tell me why cuz I
don't know they had to pay us it's not
an excuse
there's no excuse to not pay DC I don't
[ __ ] know alright so this is a fun
game they shouldn't leave Johny
Hendricks is 20% of all right you know
what that is that is our game it just
made me more depressed about last night
so let's let's finish it by this ok you
have a conversation scheduled to talk to
yourself one year ago and you get to
give them one fact about UFC 200 that
you think that they will never believe
but it's a fact
what can you think of it has like a
cohesive thought or fact telling someone
in a year ago that would think you're
crazy for saying but it actually
happened Amanda Nunez says adult that's
it oh no ok that's fair okay I would say
in one year Brock Lesnar's gonna he's
gonna fight at UFC 200 directly after
Anderson on the same UFC 200 card
carries out his four year losing streak
and Miesha Tate fights after everything
and then Miesha Tate fought for year
losing streak Anderson Silva I'd be like
nah you crazy B
you guys enjoyed this podcast of us
discussing this weirdest [ __ ] event
everything bad saving grace is the fact
that fight pass fox sports all the
prelims were basically main cards yeah
we had a bunch of great yeah lows on one
go Boston it really was like such a
mindfuck to think like even yesterday
and the day before later there are still
more fights like a guard Mousasi fought
on fight past it was yes crazy I mean
all in all I'd say the entire scope of
UFC 200 like the days leading up and
like completely spoiled it was so
[ __ ] fun yeah to watch days of fights
yeah and and I gotta say that's probably
the most entertaining week of UFC
embedded I've ever seen yeah for sure
for the good for better or worse ratios
I'd say overall yes but like yesterday
very weird but like the whole thing I'd
say it was pretty success yeah like
exactly like in 2000 ban you feel
spoiled yeah in seven days we got more
amazing fights than we've ever gotten in
any seven-day trip but it should have
been epic and it wasn't yeah well I mean
you know you can only do what you can do
and I think they tried everything but
you know we played this game and this
gave us a lot of answers when you lay
your head down tonight
make sure you pray for teams all right
Danny you all right you all right you
all right Danny you need to come out
some pizza your doctor is tired of
seeing you get you should take our skin
anyway I hope you guys enjoyed the
podcast and you don't watch fights or
MMA or UFC exactly but you don't you
don't hear this because you already
signed up make sure you check our
sponsors tracker and 5-star awesome
stuff links in the description and
please support them as it makes
really appreciate it I'll see you guys
and we